- [Instructor] We're told point A
is at negative one comma four and point C
is at four common negative six.
Find the coordinates of point
B on segment, line segment AC
such that the ratio of AB
to AC is three to five.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's work
through this together
and to help us visualize,
let's plot these points.
So first, let us plot point A
which is at negative one comma four.
So negative one comma
one, two, three, four
so that right over there is point A
and then let's think about point C
which is at four common negative six.
So one, two, three,
four, comma negative six,
negative one, negative
two, negative three,
negative four, negative five,
negative six, just like that
and so the segment AC, I
get my ruler tool out here.
Segment AC is going to look like that
and the ratio between
the distance of A to B
and A to C is three to five or another way
to think about it is B is going to be
three fifths along the way from A to C.
Now the way that I think about it is
in order to be three fifths
along the way from A to C
you have to be three fifths
along the way in the X direction
and three fifths along the
way in the Y direction.
So let's think about
the X direction first.
We are going from X equals
negative one to X equals four
to go from this point to that point.
Our change in X is one,
two, three, four, five
and so if we wanna go
three fifths of that,
we went a total of five,
three fifths of that
is going just three.
So that is going to be B is X coordinate
and then we can look on
the Y coordinate side.
To go from A to C, we are
going from four to negative six
so we're going down by
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10
and so three fifths of 10 would be six.
So B's coordinate is going to be
one, two, three, four, five, six down.
So just like that, we
were able to figure out
the X and the Y coordinates for point B,
which would be right over here
and you could look at
this directly and say,
look, B is going to be
have the coordinates.
This looks like this is
two comma negative two
which we were able to do the graph paper.
So another way you could think
about it even algebraically
is the coordinates of B,
we could think about it
as starting with the coordinates of A
so negative one comma four,
but we're gonna move
three fifths along the way
in each of these dimensions towards C.
So it's going to be
plus three fifths times
how far we've gone in the extraction.
So in the extraction to go from A to C,
you were going from negative one to four
and so that distance is
four minus negative one
and this of course is
going to be equal to five
and then on the Y dimension,
this is going to be our
A's Y coordinate plus three fifths times
the distance that we
travel in the Y direction
and here we're going from
four to negative six.
So we say negative six minus
four, that is negative 10
and so the coordinates of
B are gonna be negative one
plus three fifths times five
is going to be plus three
and then four plus three
fifths times negative 10,
well, three three fifths
negative 10 is negative six.
and so that gets us two comma
negative two and we are done,
which is exactly what
we got right over there.